now let's do the exact same addition
problem that we did in the last video
but i'm going to expand out these
numbers so that we really understand
what's going on when we're doing all of
this carrying so this five is in the
hundreds place so it really represents
five hundreds or five hundred three
represents three tens because it's in
the tens place so it represents thirty
and the six well just represents six
ones or six
likewise this three represents three
hundred
this nine is nine tens or ninety
and this eight just represents eight
ones or eight and now we can add these
two up
now let's start
let's start in the right most column
this ones column
six plus eight we've already figured out
is equal to fourteen which is the same
thing as ten plus four
ten plus four
ten
plus four so let's write the part that's
not a multiple of ten in this one's
column so let's put the 4 there and the
part that is a multiple of 10 we can now
carry into this tens column and that's
just to keep track of it just to make
sure that we don't lose that 10 we're
putting it into the tens column now we
can add all the tens 10 plus 30 plus 90
we've already figured out is a hundred
and thirty well the part that is not a
multiple of a hundred we can write in
this tens column so the 30 part and the
part that is a multiple of 100 we could
put in the hundreds column so we could
put
the hundred right over here notice we've
just carried a one but essentially we've
carried a hundred because we put a one
in the hundreds place ten plus thirty
plus ninety is a hundred plus thirty
this is equal to one hundred
one
100
plus 30. that's all we've done now we
can add the hundreds 100 plus 500 plus
300 we've already figured out is 900 so
we could write it as 900 and we're done
we've figured out that 500 plus 30 plus
6 plus 300 plus 90 plus 8 is equal to
900 plus 30 plus 4 which is the same
thing as
934. so hopefully this gives you a
little bit more sense of what we're
doing when we carry the one every time 6
plus 8 is 14 we carry the 1 that 1
represents 10 it represents this 10
right over here just so we don't lose
track of it then we say 10 plus 30 plus
90 is equal to 130 so that's 30 plus 100
30 plus 100 then we add the hundreds
together we get 900 900.